GUEST SPEAKER 1: But
we got the propellers
to start spinning
and everything.
But then, the first problem
was that the propellers
weren't spinning fast enough.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yes This
is like the motors that
were spinning the propellers.
However, the motors
are too small,
that it cannot provide enough
force for the drone to fly.
So basically, we
disassembled everything
and we get advice
from one of the clubs
on campus, which is MITERS.
And they tell us, our
drone is not going to fly.
But I know people in our
class that have seen it spin.
Like all of the four of us.
Unfortunately, we
weren't able to take
a picture of our initial drone.
But we got inspired
by it, and so, Daren,
do you want to talk about
the transmitter and receiver.
The gyroscope that we
were initially working on.
GUEST SPEAKER 3: OK,
so for the basic drone,
we got the basic sensors,
like the gyroscope.
So we managed to
get data off that
and we tried to plan a simple
way to base on the balance
until hard to
distribute the power
and arrange it so that
if it tilts this way,
the cycles will spin fast.
[INAUDIBLE] I don't know
[INAUDIBLE] I mean, it might.
If the drone is,
again, to the side,
we just add more power to the
other side to compensate for it
and try to keep it stable.
That was the initial plan.
Managed to get the
readings off the gyroscope
so we can actually distribute
the power correctly.
We were trying to control it
with a simple joystick using
RF transceivers, but
we managed to get--
it was working a few days
ago, then it suddenly
decided to break and die.
So we just scrapped
the entire idea
and just went with
direct control.
So for this [INAUDIBLE]
we just tried to--
OK.
As soon as we had
the [INAUDIBLE]
we had the [INAUDIBLE] control.
And I rotate the fan spin, so--
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Yes, so right now we
have the joystick controlling
so it has four directions.
It is going up.
Like that.
We should plug this in first.
Sorry.
GUEST SPEAKER: So we scrapped
our goal to make a drone,
because it just wouldn't work.
So we just got all the
pieces from our drone
and then put it all together
to make something else.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yeah, so the
basic science is the same.
Like we used-- we didn't
use the motor shield,
because we have a motor
driver, which is a chip that
can control the propeller.
So it's the same basic idea
of how the drone works, and we
want to use the joystick.
This is to control the
drone, as well, like up
and down control the speed
and left and right control
the servo motor that is
spinning underneath, which
is our fan right now.
So right now, I'll
control the car.
It now is accelerating the fan.
Sorry, decelerating.
Yeah.
And then it's going
back to the loop
and going to the same speed
now and then accelerates up.
[INAUDIBLE] So now it's
accelerating, right now.
So if you want to turn a
fan right now, just like--
OK, I guess the servo doesn't
like-- it works this morning,
but--
OK, so maybe--
Yeah.
Sorry I didn't really
make the thing work,
but it actually does work--
just like an hour ago, as well.
So we get the common sense
of how a drone works,
even we're maybe
taking too much--
we were envisioning
wanting to build a drone,
but then realized that
there's so much things need
to consider.
But the learning process
teaches us how to build a drone,
and we actually went to MITERS.
Do you want to say?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: OK,
so we went to MITERS
and then we showed them our
original drone design, which
is like-- they looked at
it and they were like,
oh it's not going to work,
because the motor driver can't
take that much power
to fly a drone.
And then we need a really,
really big battery to power
the motors, and we
didn't have the battery
to supply the power
in the first place.
So they're just like,
hey, we have some pieces
of a drone lying around.
You guys should
put one together.
So we put one together.
Here it is.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yes.
Well the thing
is, it is too big,
so it's very hard to
control it inside the room.
You need a very big
land of parking lot
or like a grass
land or something,
so that you can actually fly it.
So actually fly it,
and this is the basic--
the transmitter they
lent us to fly it.
And so I will
introduce this part.
So these are the stronger,
brush-less motors.
They can actually spin,
and unfortunately we
break the propellers.
That is initially all,
which is bigger than that.
But we used our propellers, as
well, to assemble to this part,
and we reprogrammed the--
so people in the MITERS
helped us reprogram the
whole speed controllers
and they get a really good
flight controllers that
can control the four motors over
here, and let's see, actually.
[INAUDIBLE] Can we
make it into the fan?
Like I will be really...
GUEST SPEAKER 4: It can
be like a something that
cleans the floor.